well coronavirus is not letting up
in our state today we're seeing a rising
test positivity rate
21.5 now let's check the numbers
right there on your screen nevada is
reporting more than 1 000 new cases
50 more people have died now here in
southern nevada
42 more people have died and only 700
new positive cases
are being reported today state officials
say these numbers are due to a delay in
lab reporting
and we should expect to see an increase
tomorrow
well more than 4 300 people in the u.s
died from covet 19
on tuesday a new single day record as
the virus continues to surge across the
country
efforts to increase the number of people
getting vaccinated
are underway people lined up outside the
new coronavirus vaccination
supersite at a disneyland parking lot
right there on your screen
in anaheim california but those who
didn't have an appointment were turned
away
in california just a quarter of the
vaccine doses received so far
have been administered it's going to
take a little bit of time for us to
catch up
a lot of logistics that come into play
well there are signs that california's
coronavirus surge is
starting to level off state health
officials say the number of daily newly
hospitalized covenant 19 patients
has dropped over the past two days
although the crisis remains far from
over
in arizona for example which leads the
nation in per capita
covet cases and hospitalizations
officials say up to
up to a 24 7 vaccination site at a state
farm stadium new york officials say
it could take up to 14 weeks for someone
to get an appointment